[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round one of the
Winter Classic here in st. Louis Jeffrey
Zhang precisely outmaneuvered Mel cumin
in the Masters for a win + R a Robson
dropped an important game to Cuban unius
ki Quesada as white in the challengers
Lucas van Forrest earned a point with
his mating net against Hawk Obion
coverage of round 2 starts now 20
international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
calm presents the second annual winter
chess classic hello everyone welcome
back to st. Louis you were looking live
in to the tournament hall at the st.
Louis chess club and for the first time
in this event all 20 players are in the
same room they're all playing so come on
into Studio B two floors below welcome
in to round number two of the 2018
winter chess classic my name is Ben
Simon and I'm joined once again by
Grandmaster in residence Jessie cry
Jessie that is an amazing time oh thank
you man yeah I got it at the Hall of
Fame across the street
really nice place silk very smooth very
smooth I got my fabi button so I'm ready
to go
very nice and a happy Election Day here
in the States to all of you hopefully
you got there out there and did your
civic duty today but we're here for some
chess and we're gonna have a really good
time so let's see where we are in Group
A after just one day of play so we had
to decisive our I'm sorry we had for
decisive games and one draw yesterday
Jesse what would you take away from this
field after the first day of play well
we have a lot of the favorites
and in particular I would say was young
saucy and motor left those guys have a
chance to run away with the tournament
and you know the way the aggressive play
of Jean 2 is kind of a question is like
he might be able to just wipe the field
here and I'm sure he's looking to do
that so very strong start for him and so
yeah I think he's the one I'm especially
watching just as kind of this is the
tournament focusing on the future of us
chess to see how well he'll do going
forward and I mean he's accumulated so
many accolades over the years but he has
won this group before in this tournament
so let's see if he could be the first
repeat champion of course we are a ways
away from the end of this thing let's
take a look at the standings for the B
group so we had two full points earned
yesterday one of them was in a game team
or garea
did not appear yesterday he had missed
his flight he is competing today and so
he forfeited that point to JJ Halima
Ronde Lukas van Forrest earned his win
over the board and here's where we stand
thus far what do you make of your old
compete reott says you would say in this
game or in this field well right so I'm
following the old guys big Mick also
known as Victor Michalowski joel
benjamin and eugene peril Stein they all
held their own with the draw and I'm
kind of you know seeing myself in them
and I recently played a tournament where
I had my own first senior moment like
the official first senior moment and big
Mick had his first I don't know if his
first it was a deadly a senior moment
yesterday but he survived you know the
young kid couldn't put him away after
big Mick
you know just overlooked something so
I'm looking at those guys but of course
this field is wide open wide open and I
wouldn't be surprised if we see Griff
who we know just dropped a point for
nothing yesterday I would that's the
kind of guy who could win this
tournament even you know starting with
an egg started with a zero a real wild
card real work hard yeah if you're not
familiar with the format let's introduce
you for the first time you're gonna be
watching 210 player round robins going
on at the same time
this is classical chess 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves there's 30 minutes
added on for the remainder of the game
after that and all along you have a 30
second increment from the very first
move so you can't stop taking notation
even if you're low on time players may
not agree to a draw
before blacks thirtieth move has been
played so this encourages fighting chess
because I mean you could play an opening
it leads to a quick draw but if you're
forced to play 30 moves right chance for
some imbalance there's definitely a
chance
yeah there's tournament schedule we hope
you stay with us the entirety there are
no rest days except for JJ Allen Rhonda
yesterday before the event began but
every day 1 p.m. the round begins and
you can watch it live at us chess champs
calm and we are on the air every day two
and a half hours after the start of the
round so 3:30 p.m. every day except for
the last day because the last day
everything starts early to make room for
playoffs if necessary
next Tuesday November 13th because there
can be only one winner in Group A and
only one winner in Group B and this
entire time we want you to join us all
over social media Facebook Twitter us
chess champs calm chess 24 I am
monitoring the YouTube chat is very
dangerous but if you want to ask us
questions you have any comments about
this guy that guy or anybody anybody let
us know and we will address them on the
air and on social media hashtag winter
chess classic to join the conversation
ok not wasting any more time let's take
a look at group a's pairings today all
of the games are still in progress
alexander Shimano versus jeffrey jog
nero
vs. ray Robson daro spirits versus
Alexander multi-level parantha milk
Quyen vs. Samsa be on and by the points
our key matchup is Krishna and SAS
akhirin vs. unis ASCII Cassata
now these two have played before
actually back in 2015 at the World Team
Championship in Armenia that was a draw
so we'll see if that's any bit different
I don't know your evaluation might say
otherwise Jessie but these are the two
players are the only two players who are
facing off today that have a full point
from yesterday so let's take a glance at
the game well it's kind of interesting
so we're just talking about the 30 move
rule and one thing I was saying was that
back in the day you know before this 30
move rule was in existence I would be
very common for gyms just to agree to a
draw in a symmetrical position like this
where it seems to me that no one really
has the advantage but you know you're at
move 20-something you gotta make 230
well someone you might feel makes a
mistake or someone might get a little
frisky and it's on this move that sassy
does get a little frisky and play c4
which it's definitely a little
controversial because now he's gonna
have a bad pawn of isolated pawn on d4
however what it is going to do if the
black takes on c4 is it will free the
knight on D 2 who is at the moment a
little bit challenged there were so many
other moves I should point out the white
could have done but c4 is gonna
unbalance the position a little bit what
it's still fundamentally pretty draw
however there's some nice tricks
actually involved with c4
based on the fact that this Bishop on f5
is only guarded by the night for example
I think the intention would be if DC
then we have Knight c5 Knight takes
bishop takes and here you're actually
losing a piece because if Bishop e6 then
there's rook e1 so there's quite a bit
of venom behind the c-4 move and of
course the simple threat going on here
is white khun's is threatening to place
c5 kicking the Knights away from the
protection of the bishop so yeah this is
where the 30 move rule comes in it comes
in because the c4 is a move is
definitely might throw black a little
bit off balance
you friends and Cassatt has been
thinking about it for a while very well
now before we move on to a B it is I
should mention that there has been a
draw
we'll look at it in a little bit between
Miro and Robson where two players came
up and the empty handed yesterday so
after 30 moves they have a draw but
let's take a look at the pairings in
Group B before we get to that all of the
games let me check
yes they're still going on Aaron a cobia
and versus Victor Michael of ski team or
garea in his first game this event
versus Nicolas Teodoro Lukas van forest
versus Robbie Kemp wish Billy Joel
Benjamin versus zabun Andrea Sian and
our key matchup this round comes from
well the highest rated highest scoring
players I guess you could say in this
matchup first time matchup Eugene peril
Stein vs. JJ a lemur Andy who is fresh
you would think because he did not play
yesterday with that buy point but let's
see what's happening on the board Jessie
right Eugene played very well after a
lemur Andy gave him a little bit of time
in the opening and in we got over here
Queenie 5 and then Harrelson plays a
very nice sequence of moves Queen rook
e1 giving the pawn and he could hear
play 97 to just win the pawn back and
have a slightly better position but
instead plays rook e2 and this is a
clever move because the Queen doesn't
quite know where to go in the game Ollie
Miranda decides to sacrifice the
exchange with queen bee 597 Queen c7
snip snip snip check to the misérable
king and rook takes a 8 and so the claim
is from black that the extra pawn and
the weakened white king side will be
enough to have enough counter play to
hold this position my intuition is that
white should still be able to win it
especially if you can trade a pair of
rooks and that is what Eugene was
able to accomplish in the next couple
moves here queen c3 was a very nice move
in fact rook e8 we should say is
controversial because you don't really
want to trade your rook in these
positions Queen c3 is a nice move
just a simple tactic we're hitting the
Queen of course on f6 and if Queen c3
we're gonna first play rook e8 and I
think black wisely says no I'm not going
to trade Queens and this position yes is
very promising for white white passed
the centralized Queen and he got black's
rook off which i think was a big
achievement and honestly it's heap to me
like black helped white egg get that
achievement so maybe that'll be
interesting you talked to Palestine
about so this position has gone from
being clearly better to probably just
winning very well the old guys the old
guys are coming through there you go hey
you never know what happens at this kind
of tournament you know when you see like
the big world elite tournaments and yeah
there's like well there's no old guys
competing unless you call cram nickeled
Anand Anand is older than you thank you
very much right right right
you got me you got me there but at these
tournaments it seems to be more of a
grab-bag when you've sealed this dynamic
quite a bit at the classic the young and
old I think it's more apparent at this
event so this is this is one of the more
intriguing couples of fields I've seen
and we've been doing this since early
2017 okay let's see what the players are
competing for there's money on the line
here in Group A a big $22,000 prize fund
where the champion goes home with $6,000
that's before tax you know that kind of
kills you all right the B group has 14
thousand dollars on the line and the
champion leaves with $4,000 very
generous prize funds
okay now Jesse you had a game that
caught your eye
Jeffry Zhong young Geoffrey Zhang in his
game let's take a look well this is one
of the most exciting games I've seen in
a while
and when you look at it you're gonna see
just absolute chaos oh and I definitely
want to spend some time on this it's
probably gonna be true I don't know it's
just probably that white is just losing
but there's quite a bit going on but I
tell you what before we get there let's
look at how the game started because I
really like the way she moneth build up
built his position here so I was
upstairs watching this and what he did
was something I very much admire is when
you can play against someone and get an
original position fairly soon and that's
what he got
so one thing that White's idea I think
is very simple here and that is that by
playing f4 early it's kind of like
imagine you're playing a Kings Indian
but you're not going to do the 91 f4 and
then back you're just gonna get it
directly you've also gotten rid of what
would be your bad Kings Indian Bishop so
white really has dreams of a fantastic
Kings Indian attack against black and
he's definitely going to get it in this
game and after e6 there was a number of
different moves that white could play
here that were interesting but watch
what she manav dust Knight b5 Queen b8
Queen d3 and this is gonna force young
Geoffrey to dislocate his king with King
East 7 now if that came at a price
because the Queen on d3 is in the way of
the D pawn and the knight on b5 was
probably gonna have to go back anyway
but what we did was we got the king out
he's not going to be able to castle
anymore and I'll say this in these
positions
obviously these players are much
stronger than me but I just want to say
that the break f4 f5 is I think the
dream of all the white players and the
idea is simply that your Bishop on c1 is
eventually going to want that die
you know let me draw that diagonal on
the board and your rook which is going
to go to f1 once this diagonal and the
reason I mention it is almost at any
point in the next couple moves I thought
f5 was what Shimano F was going to play
could have been here it could have also
been here in this position we've been
very natural to play f5 because we just
want to open the F file and also open up
this bishop here so I'm interested to
talk to the players about let's call it
my dogma
according to get the visib in the rook
immediately active with that v now Queen
e2 is played B 491 Knight g f6 so black
is slowly getting ready it feels like to
be safe and here another interesting
move c4 and it seems in consonant with
the idea of an attack but I think the
idea is is that if black does not take
on c3 that white will really start
crushing black in terms of space if he
does take on c3 in the game white took
back with the knight but there was even
the chance of also playing DC that also
seemed great you get your free
development move with the bishop what
you guys are seeing in this game is a
very rich game where there were many
different chances for different kinds of
plans and in this kind of game what
you're gonna find is that's one time
pressures and that's where we are now so
let me show you what happened Knight c3
rookie a beautiful move and now this
move e5 which honestly I don't think
white could calculate in my own dogma of
the physician right I don't like to play
e5 because I'm worried about this bishop
not getting out but the truth is here is
that what white is intending is just to
sacrifice that pawn on
five and thereby opening up the diagonal
for the bishop and the rook and it's
we're about to see it get really crazy
here by the way many different moves
here possible for Black Knight d5 Knight
h5 in the game he took and played Knight
g4 check this out d4 so he put them for
them for airily protect the pod but
while freeing our bishop that we
something we've needed to do for quite
some time see takes all right so now
we're down upon Knight g5 we're
threatening f7 I think in this position
- there was several different moves
black could play and Geoffrey plays
Knight h6 now the controversy of 96 is
just that maybe it's not going to be
that active on on h6 but on the other
hand white really needs to prove
something right now and it is
complicated he takes and I think again
Geoffrey could have played several
different moves but he plays rook h8 and
a stunner move now from Shimano off that
I am I think I understand but I'm not
sure well I'm gonna guess you okay the
move it looks logical to me yeah
Knight g5 no punches late night d5
that's right that's the that's the right
feeling of an answer okay whatever you
say buddy and I think the idea is this
if he takes then Bishop g5 and if you go
back then ecigs is actually going to
truly be crushing the very nice
conception that notice that this Knight
is covering this square so the King
can't escape and this would just be mate
very beautiful so let's go back to this
Knight d5 I think the other point is if
you play Bishop g5 then we see at the
point of rook h8 which is then black
just goes away with King e8 that's my
assumption anyway
and on Knight d5 if you go back then I
think we're gonna start planting stuff
on f6 so Geoffrey took up the challenge
he takes Bishop g5 check and now what
happens well Geoffrey said it's time to
take a walk King e6 and it is a real
question now as to whether um white is
gonna be able to find a mate he's got 12
minutes left
he's got 18 moves to go to move 40 so
definitely in my mind the game of the
round
I don't see a mate right away and the
problem is not just fighting the bay but
if you don't find the mate soon black is
going to consolidate with moves like
Knight takes e5 or and/or Queen takes e5
and so let me just get your first take
on this you know imagine you haven't
calculated anything it's complicated
would you rather be white here or black
I'd rather be white okay
because it feels like mate it yeah it
looks like the king is vulnerable the
black and the White Queen looks like you
know she has potential I'm there's no
useful checks though mmm-hmm for white
with the Queen
this is a hard but I would feel real I
think this is interesting because he's
got 10 minutes left and he knows that he
must find a good move here and I'm gonna
guess also that he's gonna have to find
more than one good move you have to find
a really nice tactical sequence or at
least idea here and then there's gonna
be more decisions down the line that
you're gonna have to make just so what
do you think about Bishop takes h6 it's
a thought I really don't like getting
rid of my bishop but let's it's a
thought so let's say takes takes just to
free up the and you want to give a check
right yeah all right and then that was
my concern with King e7
that this is for sure one of the
variations that he's looking at yeah
yeah yeah so actually what about an
interesting little little sack here rook
takes us out okay one thing I like to
say is that it's easier to sack other
pieces people's pieces but all right
let's look King at 7:00 all right Queen
takes the knight he takes the knight all
right am i dead
well I don't I don't think it's over I
think you're following a good path
because if King g8 I have to wonder
about Knight f6 right and that's
honestly my only move and then a fair
assumption would be that rook f1 is now
at the end of the world for me
it looks bad yeah it looks very scary
yeah I'll tell you that
all right so Bishop h6 let's consider it
takes well okay I guess I mean what else
you gonna do you could maybe play Queen
you could hide so much you could do
honestly isn't yeah
also maybe Queen e5 yeah I mean there's
so many but on Queenie five Queen g4
let's check your variation again because
that was nice
Bishop h6 check to the misérable King
King e7 takes that's clean that's you
know that's the party right there okay I
like that a lot so he's gonna have to
consider something like rook takes
Knight but this doesn't feel good to me
because of check and if you go back now
my bishop gets to do stuff okay but
here's a special trick you would like to
play east six but you're probably gonna
get made it on h2o yeah yeah
oh this is fun okay so yeah we're we are
in this position right now he's thinking
let's stay here for a little hold on so
yeah if this hat okay so the e6 Queen
takes h2
the king can pop out after - right right
in the bummer there is not only did he
take take you but now he's taking your
rook on f1 out of the attack right
that's the truly sad thing yeah okay so
like maybe 95 now or something like that
I just intuitively I would say black is
now doing better than fine because of
the king being out let's look at that
again see one front row cage seven
maybe Bishop no but I don't think Bishop
g5 the problem with Bishop g5 is then
Queen e5 and if Queen g4 I have f5 and
there's no check alright because my
bishops in the way so let's try it again
oh wait a second
okay this is it this is probably not
going to work I just want to check oh
but you know even a rook f6 he could
just go back
god what a mess huh what a mess
okay there's a lot that can happen so
queasy for and kingi seven I'm just yeah
kingi five I can win the Queen Bishop f4
is there something else okay
yeah this is very frightening man oh man
because even if you played something
lame like Bishop g7 rook g7 rook AE one
the attack is still coming we're still
gonna play things like e6000 sugar and
spice it's gonna be rough
so Jeffrey's earning it here his
opponents who I'm gonna say I really
admire Alex just moved he built up his
position he took the night I believe he
took tonight yeah it's a Bishop h6 and
rook takes happened almost instantly and
now he's got six minutes left and right
we were anticipating now queen g4 that
happened did it happen yeah he just
plays it Alex oh because you're watching
us yeah very beautiful okay it's a good
way to cheat now yeah we t4 and Keaney 7
happened and now white needs a good move
so let's go through it the slow play way
would be Bishop g7 or okay e1 though I'm
gonna guess they're that black is
actually fine for example Brooke ad one
night f8 is a nice defensive because you
just bring your knight to e6 and that
should be enough huh
and right and it's funny you know with
very strong players often times they
will see tricks like the way we're
talking about in like from far away and
and especially the trick that East six
is not going to work because of a queen
age too
maybe we can do this
oh that looks evil what about that
here's a good move Bishop takes and our
rook defends f7 I like that one right oh
this is hot
this is when you walk around the
tournament hall and you say well I'm
either completely lost or I'm completely
winning I know what I am here and this
is beautiful stuff and let's stay here
because jimana has five minutes left and
he definitely needs a good move now he
has chosen Queen g5 and I'll say just
from experience this is the phase of the
game where both players are going to be
making significant amounts of mistakes
like when you just look at the computer
or something so we should expect that
both players are going to be doing funky
things here
I think Queen g5 has a nice idea and
that is when you go back then I can play
ecigs and it also asks Geoffrey a
question of do you want to try to repeat
the position with King e6 right and if
nothing else even if shamanic beliefs he
is better here he would definitely
appreciate the chance to repeat the
position just a little bit just to get a
little more time on his clock so kind of
a good move by saman often to ask black
a question so I'm gonna just point out
some things let's say King f8 right okay
I believe the intention has to be e six
all right there's a lot of different
moves here for black one of them might
even be this beauty here Queen h2 check
to the misérable King takes takes
however this does not work because of
rook takes yeah that's getting okay okay
so and there's all kinds of things here
but e six would be the big question and
the point of this whole business is that
we're getting east six in without black
having the chance to immediately kill us
however I'm just there's a lot of
questions here like let's say I just
take this guy and invite your rook in
and ask you are you really winning this
probably not probably not so we can see
Jeffery thinking on it you know I'll say
this about Jeffery last game to really
controlled the clock and here he's up
twenty minutes to five minutes and it's
a big deal it is a very big deal to be
up that much time in position like this
Jeffery should definitely you know
figure out his next couple moves I have
it might even be true that there's more
than one move that's winning here but
King f8 that seems like the first the
first choice because again on e6 there
might be more than one move for black
but that looks pretty simple because of
the counter play against h2 well let's
let let me be devil's advocate then so
rook f7 King g8 I think taking on d7 is
asking for it so let's say h3 no no
right I'm just I'm just bringing out all
my guys all the guys are coming out okay
oh this is a good one so it looks like
maybe Jeffery is clearly winning after
King f8 is there another idea here for
white maybe Bishop g7
it doesn't feel right but the idea would
be if rook d7 then we could play e6
anyways go back for a second yeah so
this position okay so a King f8 my knee
an issue here okay
Queen takes g6
let's that's a good move Bishop h6
yeah just take the rook right take the
rook and then let's say check King h1
and 95
I don't know I don't know
yeah that's pretty that's pretty crazy
there might be something else after
Queen g6 but I think it's I'm glad you
pointed it out because it's one of the
many things that black has to worry
about in his choice now right whether
it's FTE six or eight shimano of his
traded bishops
on g7 oh he but he but black went to e8
yes
AEA and then the bishop trade now one
thing I guess I had a question about was
what was going to happen on e6 scary to
me but okay let's assume that Jeffrey
had something for that and instead we
got Bishop takes rook takes and now you
know I'll say that's Jeffrey it's like
King e8 pretty quick I'm sure I would
have spent more time if I had twenty
minutes left but I guess he's confident
here and honestly now white really needs
something amazing because we are very
close to shutting everything down now
with moves like Knight f8 and or ninety
five actually night you know it's like
so let's say this the problem for black
is the rook on g7 is not especially
great and might be a victim too like if
ninety five Queen f6 it might be a
victim and of course it's not doing the
counter play on h2 still very much
believed in blacks position here but
this is where this is why people a lot
of strong players stop playing the
Sicilian is because accidents happen in
positions like this terrible accidents
and then you're just lost like you know
let's imagine be six for example let's
imagine F
and then you know there's all kinds of
things to worry about here after
Saybrook 81 I believe that blacks
winning but I'm scared you know I mean
there's a time to bring it if you're
black I mean bring the queen up to ya
and we will definitely want to get our
lady to protect her man
that's what she wants Oh a six a so
three minutes left and Jim onif knows
that he has to find something now or
else the game will end and I'll say you
know one thing about these players who
play against Cecilia who loved playing
efore this is very nerve-wracking for me
but it's also what they live for love to
play the positions like this where
everything's on the line it could go
either way
one question may be to ask for black 2
is what's gonna happen after Queen age 6
yeah it's not entirely clear to me how
Geoffrey wants to play that
so lots of questions two minutes left so
let's go through the candidate moves he
could play be six now he could play rook
AE 881 or between h6 on rook 81 I didn't
like the fact that night f8 seems to
like gum up the works there might be
other things too but I was afraid of
that but maybe you could play that way
you'd have to have some idea right in
order to do that always really ticking
down
oh I remember that mean there is a
30-second increment but it's still not a
lot of time no you could think about a
30-second increment has been a great
thing for chest but the thing about a
position like this is not only do you
have to calculate well but you have to
find ideas like it's hard it's like hard
to generate interesting ideas and
positions like this to give your
opponent brief I'm gonna root for Queen
h6 not that I'm sure about it but at
least after this maybe we can start with
in e6 now or you know black would also
maybe have to I don't think rook takes
f7 that's gonna work but even that he
has to worry about a little bit all
right all right something was just
please nothing was played Queen know he
played rook 81 that's in fact what
happened and positionally it makes a lot
of sense because we're bringing all the
last pieces in and Geoffrey should
definitely take some time here because
he has loads of different potential
moves he can do he can bring his Queen
in he can move his Queen somewhere he
can play Knight f8 like we talked about
let's just see if there's any way to
crack Knight a fate because that looks
like the way the natural way that I
would first you know think about facing
down this position honestly it looks
totally lost to me if you play Queen f6
again we're coming to rook h7 and that
means you can no longer play e6 because
of h2 so you got a sac the pawn I guess
with e6 but I yeah I don't see how
you're gonna
maybe Queen f6 now maybe that's the
intention okay maybe that's the
intention so we're threatening to take
this guy and if Rick h7 we have rookie
six takes and queen g6 that's a nice one
yeah that's a nice one so at least 9 f8
has a potential issue with Queen f6 or
excuse me with a 6
and even and notice if context then you
have to worry about Queen f6 you might
be able to get away with a move like f5
that's another way for black just try to
survive this but with the pond deep in
the in your gut there it's going to be a
little bit unpleasant still this might
be it
you know like night h7 and if Queen h6
king f7 something like this so all kinds
of moves here for black and this might
actually be well I'm gonna hope that
Geoffrey just thanks for a good I would
be I would think for 10 minutes here
because if he finds the solid defense
then that's it you know and he everybody
doesn't want any accidents to happen so
why don't we take a look at the milk Umi
in game yes we could do that let's see
yes Malcolm young chubby on in group a
very interesting game and I just want to
highlight I really like the way that
milk Umi and played the opening very
original and he came up with I think
what's a novelty here with the
strange-looking 92 and the idea is
simply to ghost the bishop on d4 so
right now we're threatened to win the
thing with a 3 B 4 so a 5 a 3 and now we
get this nice tempo and
very rich strategic game here that went
on I thought this position was White's
big moment where you know should he
ignore him taking on f3 or should he as
in the game just calmly go back by going
back I feel like you give black the
ability to play d5 and I don't know
probably be equal but this is gonna be
anyone's game
Bishop e8 I like by the way too because
it looks kind of weird but you're gonna
free the rook and you're opening up the
bishop here rook FD 1 it looks honestly
now it looks right it looks like Savion
has a nice tug here oh yeah this is oh
very very nice for for Samuel oka c8 a
little bit of dancing now and here's our
position well I think we should say
white has tried kind of like yesterday
with Ron McMillion scape where things
didn't go quite his way he then you know
started to bunker down that's definitely
it looks like what we have here and
really when we look at it all of Samuels
pieces are engaged have some kind of job
so this looks like a very promising
position for black here so maybe two
black wins and the key games
yeah it could happen let's take a look
in Group B okay it looks like Aaron
Akopian the other Armenian one of the
other Armenians in this tournament has
really got Victor Bukowski on the ropes
right yeah let's take a look at how this
happened Bishop g5 has been popular for
a while let's call it with the the not
so fancy GM's but now the fancy GM's
have also started playing Bishop g5
mostly as a way like Carlos played it
Magnus has played it as a way of getting
an original position
and the original idea here was to take
on f6 immediately but black delays it
and then we transpose into the
traditional Bishop g5 variation and
let's say this black has an unopposed
bishop the bishop on c5 which is the
pride of his position let's jump over to
parish lines game propane is about to
win his game against JJ a Lima
rendezvous game what we clan stand a
little bit earlier on you oh yeah this
is about over right now
JJ away from the board
yeah I noticed that since we left it the
night on e 8 hasn't moved at all right
so the dream of blacks was that his
knight was going to be able to create
some counter play against the white king
but it hasn't been able to do so and
here apparel Stein's just looking for a
nice way to finish the game rook d4
jumps out and anybody looking at it but
there's other moves here too so a lot of
good moves here rook d8 might work Queen
c3 might work f4 might work they all
look pretty good in fact f4 might just
be immediately leading to some kind of
obvious mate at 4 that's what happened
and black took it is if I see right
through the screen he has no choice
and now I'm gonna imagine rook D for now
but there might be other things look D
for it's hard to imagine that rookie 4
isn't going to be made right right yeah
you know I don't think you're escaping
from that one
well count this as one for the old guys
this is a beaut here alright so it
worked before King Nephi and well king
e5 will lose instantly to Queen III King
f5 rook F for King g5 and if nothing
else you go win the Queen right well I
mean besides King e5 the only thing you
could do is put the Queen in between
right well you can play King g5 oh this
is also completely terrible same deal
rook g4 king f5 rook c4 win the quaint
mm-hmm now Paris I might want to find
mate there but for us I think that's
good yeah he's just call me thinking
about he's got a good 13 minutes and
they have also reached 40 moves so he's
gonna be in no hurry to finish this one
off but yeah that's gonna be done soon
let's go back to big mix game and big
Mick had some you know he had two bucks
in a row here as I was saying with this
Bishop you know it's very simple what
White's saying he's saying that the
long-term structural problem on blacks
King side will mean that he'll have
practical chances against the black King
and that's really precisely what ends up
happening here I've got a result good in
Group A Geoffrey Zhang has indeed won
his game with the black pieces against
Alexander Shimano off I suppose well
what will get those guys in the Geoffrey
Jean down here for an interview yeah at
the end it was so hard when you have no
time and there might not have been
anything there anyway right but without
any time to fine
the ideas yeah you're in trouble yeah so
we'll bring him in a second beautiful
not only beautiful but like when you
play the Sicilian like that that's some
risky stuff that's a really risky stuff
so Bishop g7 and now a very nice play
from white against Victor c4 rook back
queen c3 and what this says to black is
that f5 is gonna lose tonight f6 now one
thing I don't entirely understand is why
big Mick didn't then play d5 because in
the game he allows he does an
interesting thing he allows white to
take on f6 I suppose with the
interesting idea that the night is now
pinned to the Queen but of course Knight
g5 you need an answer - oh this is very
nice 94 and then he just gives up the
bishop threatening mate but we lose the
Bishop h6 and rook 81 very nice very
nice so let me just tell fans what the
idea is let's say you try to trade and
then it's play a move like b6 you're
gonna get hit with rook d8 Queen takes
Knight f7 mate and it's kind of hard to
stop it
you can't develop your Bishop to d7 it
looks like a victor has resigned the
game congratulations - Arin Akopian we
might let's we've had some good
attacking games this round yeah and we
might have a train of some good
interviewees because I understand that
we do have Geoffrey Zhang ready to come
in for an interview great so I take a
look around the horn and I will be back
after the interviews all right
yeah let's get that game up and won't
have Jeffrey come in yeah so be great so
we're gonna ask Jeffrey a bunch of
different questions here starting with
the OB I'm hoping we have time to talk
to him when he comes in about I mean of
course we have time to talk to but in
depth about all the different things
that were going on in this game
while we're doing that let's peek at
while we're waiting let's look at Sal's
game and it looks like Samuel found a
really decisive shot let's back up a
second we stopped looking right around
here so Bishop f5 Queen Bee to Knight g5
and Iran says well if I'm going to
suffer I might as well get a pawn and
then Knight age three is on the board so
that's the grief that her aunt is facing
right now and I'm gonna guess this is
lost but it's still very complicated all
right we have Geoffrey Jean coming in
here and the question let's just leave
it here for Smith Samuel for a second
and um the problem for for Arad is he
has to decide whether he wants to move
to kick or take the knight yes it looks
bad alright now we'll come back to this
game after the interview with Geoffrey
and so let me welcome Jeffrey for being
here and a very nice victory let me pull
up this game I was sweating for you yeah
okay yeah I I really admired actually
the way he built up his attacking
position you know let's walk through
this I have a bunch of questions I want
to ask you alright so check and you
played 97 quickly yeah but I mean it was
more over the board inspiration I mean
he surprised me in the opening and right
I didn't quite know this position okay
now let me give you my my amateurs
appreciation of this position so I think
that he's like has a dream here and it's
like the Kings Indian exhale like super
accelerated it got rid of his bad Kings
Indian bishop he's gonna play f4 without
going night you know II ate back to f6
he's getting like all the whole dream
and so that's why this position I was
like oh this is dangerous yeah I
probably I didn't realize
how dangerous it would be for me because
basically the other choice is like I
know Queen d7 was played in Gary game
uh-huh and it was also very dangerous
for blacks so that's why it took I mean
just try something new and hope for the
best but yeah this also turned out to be
quite dangerous right
actually there was some old Fischer
games I remember he played you can play
a six if you really yeah yeah if I
expected okay well let's look f 4g 693
Bishop g7 Queen e2 and I thought that
was kind of tricky yeah we got B nine of
six and then also I think he well maybe
he came up with the next idea on the
board but after ecigs he decided to put
your king in the center well I think I
think 95 was good but I think Queen d3
was was not correct I thought okay if he
just plays f5 it would be very very
tough I'm glad you brought that up
because I felt like almost anywhere in
the next couple movie where there's
several chances for him to play f5 yeah
and just in my dogmatic sense of how to
understand these positions I like I want
to bring the bishop out and I want to
bring the rook in so almost anytime I
can play f5 I don't care if you win the
pawn if I just want to open everything
so you didn't like Queen d3 I thought I
mean I still thought he I still like
White's position right well you just
thought what maybe f5 right away yeah
because I have that Queen jerries
wasting time because he basically has to
bring the Queen back later on I develop
his bishops all right that's not worth
the time that's a fair point but still
f5 here that would have scared me
f5 yeah f5 here's also a move
I probably would have just ignored it
right uh also I felt okay here's where I
was like Jeffries he's he's a brave man
it's like they all just play b5 you
could have done other things I imagine
yeah I could have played 9 f6 there but
I wasn't sure like he maybe he can play
a 4 and then I kind of wanted to expand
on the queenside as fast as possible at
least I didn't see any problem with it
right ok but definitely dangerous
yeah I thought he might try f5 here then
I would probably have played Knight of 6
and yeah he opens that foe but I thought
I'm quite well developing house it would
be let's imagine f5 Knight of 6 and at
some point probably you'll take I'll
take take 622 maybe 95 now yeah 95 was
always possible but I think here yeah
you I guess
so if I play aged 61 at age 3 is that
the concept I'm just I'm just telling
you about my fears I was playing this
position but right if but more simply
put regardless of what he does here he's
achieved something with opening the F
file yeah right yeah all right so cui
t2v 491 and now you played nine GS 6 one
thing I admired about this game was
there so many different plans for both
sides it's not like yesterday you didn't
have as many different plans before that
both sides and here those several moves
as a co so many different things are
possible I still wanted him to play a 5
here um f5 but now I can now I have this
idea to play Jeff in a 5 which i think
is good for blind
ok cuz I have a big Center and the King
will be quite safe
I mean queen is very ideal
he's seven like this yeah so I'll just
play cleanest energy and so on okay I'm
still scared like d3 and probably bring
the night in maybe put a bishop there
yeah I might I was thinking if you go d3
I might play h6 just to write completely
limited edition all right okay no it's
true I think the longer you wait with f5
the the less poem it's gonna be right
and c4 was an interesting idea did you
feel this was an interesting choice
whether you took or not or was it just
obviously I I think it's it's it's
actually it's possible not to take but I
prefer taking because I mean it's it's
hard to evaluate this position when I
don't take like if I played rook e8 now
uh-huh but yeah it's a very slow
manoeuvring game probably play 98 96
because right when you I felt like if
you don't take then your Queen side play
kind of just is gonna end yeah yeah
right yeah that's interesting
I thought his he played I think this
kind of quickly if I remember right but
I thought D take C was also very yeah
but D takes I thought I can just play
Ruby 8 because now it's hard for him to
set up his pieces I think I don't know
what like I thought he's obligated to
try Yi five now but then I just play 95
but look he's got that beautiful pawn
and C 3 he could play this slow as well
well I'm I'm not sure I mean somehow III
don't know how you said your pieces like
deeply 9 of 10 that would be an old man
move that I might make yeah yeah yeah I
just yeah it's an interesting well
actually let me ask you this when you
play B takes c3 what were your thoughts
you thought yeah I expected DC yeah yeah
but I thought I was doing fine I thought
maybe you thought you were fine here
oh man I'm scared for you I thought II
five was a good sign for you just cuz it
didn't feel like the right move
but but otherwise I'm blinking FHA right
so I didn't see right right and here you
actually had a bunch of different
choices here as well right um I thought
I thought only Knight h5 would takes you
could maybe do Knight d5 295 I
considered briefly but I wasn't I don't
think I considered it for so long
maybe it's Paulson possibly I'm it just
seemed to me like one problem for him
and playing me fives I don't see how he
could calculate it right because there's
so many different moves that you can do
and that's true now we're gonna enter
like the new tactical phase and he's
running into time pressure and it's like
he needs to find fights of ideas I kind
of like what he did against you unless
maybe you have a different idea of what
yeah well I think well seeing what
happened in the game I mean I missed
on this night age then but like if you
go back maybe I should play at age 5
because it looks safe for anyways
right now at age 5 looks safe I was
thinking um 9h 5d 4d 4 I'll take on d4
he has to take king of fate and yeah I
think I was beautiful aqua enough to
okay so if I play campaign I'm not sure
but all I know is that I don't worry too
much about it this this business is
scary yeah you mean you can maybe play a
move like d3 I might be able play d3
right and just give the question back to
you about yeah cuz you're yeah you're
all certainly g-force right you have to
be very careful yeah maybe this is not
so clear so this was true madness now do
you feel comfortable positions like this
[Music]
yeah you can't get out of it alright so
d4 I never was a nice is nice idea yeah
I had to stop playing the Sicilian
because stuff like this happened to me
accidents happen accidents
I figured you probably had more than one
move here no no I think it's I just
totally horse to play in aged six so I
mean if I take money five he's got work
of sevens so yeah this was very clever
night h7 and oh yeah
this is frightening yeah it's just your
objective assessment what did you feel
here like what I couldn't evaluate right
right I thought but yeah I felt very
fortunate to have rookie Jake because I
guess like the most obvious one is Queen
e5
let's just see I wasn't sure if I'm
worse or not maybe I'm he'll play Bishop
g5 f 625 and 85 9 of 6 yeah maybe I'm
actually because I thought dc-3 has a
knight h5 this is probably an issue yes
maybe this is just bad for me
well okay yeah very complicated yeah
rook h8 and you know I I admired what he
did I mean yeah I think he was forced to
play this 95 at least I didn't see
anything that was exciting
that was almost movie he was he was
ready to knock you eat eggs check and
then our sense here in the booth was it
if you went to ei then e 6 would be
really rough I think so yeah well I
wasn't sure if I was lost or not because
I have Queen e5 I wasn't sure if I'm
lost but I mean I didn't say anything
wrong with Keaney 6 so I decided right
and here again he didn't have that much
time though I think the only other
option for him is rook c1 but it doesn't
really help him because I go Queen b6 so
I covered c6n aether and d3 so I think
taking was correct could you've gotten
away I was thinking maybe Knight f6
Knight but Knight of 6 if if I just take
on e5 I mean with the Queen yep I mean I
have no idea what's happening but I
assume something like that oh but ok so
he took and let's show the fans the
problem with what was it Bishop h6 this
was kind of interesting we were seeing
Queen g4 rook f7 yeah check to the
miserable King King ta Knight f6 and I
didn't analyze it but just seemed like
that yeah
yeah yeah I didn't analyze it either I
always assumed yeah yeah yeah
so here we go excuse me
rook eight seven well played and here
he's under immense time pressure but you
think he has any other chance what do I
have a feeling that it's a draw
that's my feeling but I didn't see how
to how to make the drop for white
that's so just like a gut feeling you
should be able to that's interesting
yeah I mean because Queen on beard and
rook on a door out for the moment so I
feel like I should have some way but
yeah I did not see it I guess queen g4
is probably correct all right and one
thing we were talking about it's the
unfortunate thing for him is that if he
plays Bishop g5 then he can't really
play e6 because yes you ever play yeah
if he had that you'd be in big trouble
yeah so yeah I didn't see it I didn't
really see anything for him I was
looking all kinds of stuff Queen g5 was
there was King f8 just as good as King
e8 or no PFA I thought is is not good
because Queen g6 so I'd have to play
King Jade I mean but this I mean he at
least has drawn there oh I was thinking
maybe you'd like take check and like
that or something ah but this this is
probably this might be this is pretty
scary though I don't know yeah no I
didn't know I just thought was the other
one that I guess I saw so King he ate
and here he took which seems to be like
a capitulation away just I don't know
what I think he has to yeah because if
it was e six I think I take money chicks
with the bishop right that's right let
me actually let me show that so e six
takes and it's it's nice that your rook
is covering this guy
right so I don't know edie king of
fayefaye there's not not long I thought
yeah he has to take one of seven but I
assume that I'm fine yeah yeah yeah yeah
that has to be fine
okay so Bishop g7 takes yeah so maybe
instead of rook e1 he was saying that
this is probably the critical moment he
could played Queen oh yeah wish this was
critical here yeah that's that was the
move I was thinking of yeah I have to go
route g8 then the thing is rook f7 if I
take it to drop I think I take on u5 so
should be when with the Queen yeah cuz
now I have 23 that's the problem so he
has to go like work of three but I feel
I should have some kind of defense
yeah this is
and you could castle right no no you get
castle
it'd be nice of you that would be a
shocker if you could good castle all
right but yeah let's see if we can find
something here so we're saying Queen h6
rook g8 and now is the question if he
could
okayyyy six I'll just take 27 work of
fate and the King all is just finding
some shelter like on d6 so you so say
take although yeah it's not like he's
seven Queen g7 maybe King d6 Queen g3
now yeah I can block with I should
probably block with the night yeah cuz
Queen 813 d7 a it's okay
so that's just for kicks or a keyboard
yeah you should turn if you want okay
fine can you do this kind of business
but yeah I've quit h8 though so like
1000 you're right I didn't see Queenie
tape yeah
yes um especially with no times just
hard to calculate all these lines and
there's just so many things maybe even
some like that Brooksie one okay
so yeah this is my stuff like this it's
I don't think I have any serious threat
honestly it's just in temp to play on
yeah I want to take on b2 I I'm trying
to see what you were give your I'm gonna
see if I do yeah I don't think I don't
think I have anything I mean the best
I've got is something no I
yeah yeah no I don't have anything there
so something like that though I mean
yeah it smells like there should be
something but maybe it's very difficult
alright because yeah in the game I think
it's important because after rook a1
maybe like some more natural move was
Knight a fate or 95 mm-hmm but I think
after e6 I'm only I can be in trouble
there interesting right that was that
I'm glad you said cuz that was my first
instinct and then the more we looked at
it it was like oh maybe it's Gary so
this move that is a very good some down
right it's the same reason his whole
attack hasn't been working is the
counter play on the h2 pond yeah yeah
and here he played Queen g3 but
unfortunately not in time but I think
like now I can bring the knight right
wing g3 it's hard to imagine that as a
navigator c5 yeah
do anything all right very nice game you
to know who are you playing tomorrow
I've got Asus if you're on okay that's
the big game yeah I think I guess
well his position today I guess is about
equal so yeah well actually let's uh
let's peek in I was gonna peek into that
position anyway I get your opinion it
looked
oh it is a draw it looked rosh honestly
the whole yeah and you're gonna be white
or yeah all right well good luck
tomorrow and we're gonna go to a
commercial break after the effort leaves
us alright
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advised from
the best and even challenged them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
and you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game heading back
to the hotel would be a major error
instead
boogie through the city and discover the
music that gave the Blues their name at
the National Blues Museum Broadway
Oyster Bar or even the legendary
Blueberry Hill
so whether you love the Cardinals the
Blues or the Blues come play with us
you guys know I can't play this right
st. Lou is always exploring alright
we're back with Eugene Harrelson who
just had a very nice win over a lemur on
D and my favorite one of my favorite
quotes of the tournament so far Eugene
said I played like an old man that felt
good yep yeah let's look you know I had
a bad reputation for a long time because
I would I would just any variation I
would take like five so they called me
take five that's what they called me
take five like I did exchange Kings in D
and the whole spirit and one thing I was
jealous with you and about here was
since I normally play Knight of three I
couldn't do this variation that you
played with Bishop G yeah it's a tricky
line I've played it before pretty good
record with it but looks like my
opponent wasn't quite familiar with this
line right because it felt like after a
six yeah a little better yeah I just
have a good Bishop his Bishop a stock
one c8 it's pretty comfortable position
right and I just want to play e3 Bishop
d3 it's like a dream of change love yes
agree and a lot of times on the exchange
Slav the bishop okay I should just point
out to chest ants that often the normal
move is Bishop f4 right but on f4 it
sometimes doesn't exactly know what it's
doing there
yeah plus sometimes black can play 9006
Bishop g4 and this is I'm threatening to
double his pause at the moment so it's
not obvious what he should be doing
right and I felt like the next couple
moves he gave you what I think are the
oh he fulfilled the dream yes 36 even if
I didn't really analyze this deeply I'm
pretty happy and I thought that moved to
that hadn't been
nice feeling yeah I've never seen Knight
h5 before typically they play castles on
the 98 and try to give Knight to d6 sure
right but okay he decided to trade the
bishops which is typical it some lines
but here it's like you're getting the
nice dark square bishop Soph
right the night is gonna owe you a tempo
- exactly and then I have the ninety
five a four plus yeah you've got
everything gently not so takes and 9595
yes so if he plays the native six I just
play a four and this is like a dream
right let's put that on the board yeah I
guess I'd call this a Pillsbury
pillsbury attack yeah so II Foursquare
is very important on the control thing
when I play Queen f3 two for Queen h3
and just go for the free attack and one
way to talk about this is to say and a
normal Pillsbury black might have on say
a dark square Bishop and we would have
some terrible yep here or sometimes
there's a bishop on b7 and they try to
get ninety four to block that on hey
yeah
so black arguably makes a more
controversial decision yes I kind of
expected he made you this because he
didn't really want to suffer so g6 now
the game is very dynamic because if I
don't play what I did in the game he's
about to play castle on f6 right and
then my Center is gone so I think Bishop
e2 is very strong okay for tonight did
you sell now for yeah berry and if it
takes 94 I'm just dominated mm-hmm so I
think the ship c6 is reasonable I take
he takes in the hubba ship f3 this is
all because you're up in time yes it's
all about time so here he Castle I think
hard to find a better man yeah I think
he has to do and we briefly mentioned
that instead of 95 I had this
interesting idea of rook e1 and if he
plays rook 88 now Bishop takes d5 and
I'm intentionally dependent myself but
if he plays Queen c5 which looks like
really bad position for white now 94 94
and look at this tactics like Knight of
6 or slow and if he plays Queen a5 I
can't play Knight f6 check or even
Knight d6 oh no you can't
the united states native six truck the
marine a59 f6 and now this beautiful
idea queen c1 uh-huh I had like similar
idea in the game but this is even better
because I maintain the e5 stronghold oh
it's like van forest yesterday yeah yeah
all right unfortunately that didn't
happen I like what you did it was very
95 the old man yeah it's an old man who
I knew that I'm at least equal all the
complications but I'm gonna go for it so
he has to go for all this Queen sex
Ricky one Queen d2 rookie - I thought
that okay so I thought this is an
interesting moment yeah I think let's
just note that the Queen has some
problems in the game black chooses to
sacrifice exchange yeah that was a
little puzzling to me maybe it's not a
bad practical choice but Queen a3 is
what I was worried about right and I was
wondering to myself because I couldn't
see it directly how are you were gonna
knock him out here but I'm saying myself
Eugene see something here that I didn't
say a killer blow I was thinking about
the rookie 3 here uh-huh
and so I think you can play a queen beat
you back we're even Queen c5 and it's
still unclear where am i attacking a fun
Wow look we know 85 there's a problem so
if you play Queen a five-night of six
check that was my at me and idea King h8
now I take one c6 and Luke h3 and now
he's got major major problem so the h5
looks bad yeah and it makes you want say
my dear that's beautiful well so because
I have a feeling mm-hmm that let's just
say that the problem the problem of
course is that you're forcing is Queen
to leave the f6 square right so it might
just be that when you turn on the
computer it's gonna find something
amazing anyway boys may just find the
perfect defense black holes you were
concerned with Queen C or Queen B - both
of these options I thought were better
than the game well yeah what would you
do it but Queen okay well obviously I
can repeat the room key to if I want to
draw but you know I obviously don't want
to draw
so I'm not sure I mean Ruby one I can
sack more pawns okay that brings me this
question so when you decided oh yeah why
what made you sure about rookie to
rookie to versus rugby one I mean the
other old man thing you could do of
course even after rookie to Queen a3 is
you could try to go and get the end yeah
well that's why I thought off to rukiye
to worse case in there I can repeat and
then I can go to the end game right I
can play rookie 3 Queen B 2 and I can go
for them now I want you guys to see this
man is the Russian chess training always
repeat always repeat I have a hard time
doing in actual games but I know that it
is the correct psychologically
devastating thing to do to your right
okay well let's look Queen D fun yeah
Queen d5 was very unexpected but there
is some king side damage to my pawns 3
you're talking about this and yeah I was
saying that obviously the hope is with
the pawn and with your damage King
started it maybe he can somehow hold
this yeah if I can trade either a pair
of Queens or a pair of ropes it's pretty
much game over I'm glad you said that
because I would that seemed like in the
game maybe I didn't understand it
quickly but it seemed like he helped you
yeah I think you blunder at the Queen c3
that's what gets right yeah so here I
play the Queen B III yeah let me just
ask what about Queen d7 I thought that's
what you were going to do also looks
reasonable
okay yeah I mean enough six maybe queen
is six so pressure when they won an f3
oh yeah well your moves better yeah
maybe three simple yeah so there's a
simple choughs
v6 queen III so I'm gonna get the
Queen's off obviously I want to trade
rook c1 sets up the trap with rukia's
Queen c3 and he's just lost after that I
think Rudy Avis he's better try d8 here
okay with the other weird thing about
rook e8 is like let's say that for
whatever reason the trap isn't there
right isn't it still the case that like
after Queen d3 you didn't want your
robbed if you can play room do you eight
know maybe you know yeah all right um
but yeah obviously he doesn't want to
trade yes a queen c3 nice trick yep yeah
no this was just over totally over eight
and one thing I said in the broadcast
and maybe you'll back me up on this my
dogma in these positions is that the
rooks when you got two of them they kind
of do the same thing yeah yeah and the
rook and Knight are doing different
things so if you get rid of the rook yep
it's devastating yup that's exactly
right yeah and so I was like it when I
see my dog was confirmed by other people
this is absolutely very simple Queen CC
I think this is just over and it's night
actually never even gets back into the
game yeah it's a very nice yeah so i
induced f6 to weaken the King mm-hmm
and now it's pretty much any trade is
bad so he decided to kind of commit
suicide or the King Martian it I'm
waiting like 5,000 different ways here I
know that you didn't try to mate him yes
I took his queen because that's what old
man yeah that's what old man do I just
said between you know or like Karpov
said I just go into King and pawn in the
game and I went I don't know check me
right right well beautiful yes so now
you've got a point in half ever were you
playing tomorrow I think I'm playing the
young Greek Theodora yes
it's gonna be a good mansion how did he
do today I don't know let's check
sometimes I have trouble finding always
oh that was a draw did your okay
Oh against teamwork actually that's a
great segue because chess fans I am
forcing this on the st. Louis chess club
we are gonna watch
okay
[Music]
and welcome back to the 2018 winter
chess classic what a video that is
Bensimon along with grandmaster jessie
cry the free spirit of chess team or
gurov jumps out of a plane lands in st.
Louis I love it
I want to try to show it if that was not
him landing actually in st. Louis that
was a during a photo shoot for that
amazing chest Life magazine cover that
you saw there at the end what a great
video to have that might be one of the
the best chess related videos of the
year perhaps oh yeah that's one of the
best of all time yeah yeah you know
anything anyone's done that before Jim
no only with a chess board no so we've
had a lot of happenings and this is the
last time I was here right and I mean
Jeffrey of course beat the far and away
the star of the round and maybe
eventually at the tournament but we do
have games still in progress
can we please glance at mel kuma and
sevilla yes hit up on the board here yes
let's take a look because this is things
have changed this is last time we took a
look is it is it possible to get the
game there we go okay yeah it is a mess
the Queen's just got off which might
make it easier for me to understand the
position when we left it seemed to me
like Savion had all the chances but now
it's very unclear what's happening we've
reached move 40 it looks unless unless
black has some voodoo magic right now it
looks to me like
the man's gonna win this game it's not
only the extra exchange but he's got
this pawn on a six am I missing anything
looks bad yeah I don't see anything else
there let's let's go back when we've
left this position it was night takes
edge age three and it looked incredibly
frightening for white and he then played
King H one very cool customer King age
one and it might turn out that this
night h3 you know when I saw it I was
just assumed that it was over for white
but King h1 now that there's two
problems the knight on h3 is still
attacked and the pawn on c6 is attacked
so Savion does the most armenian thing
you can do he sucks the exchange and
that comes back it looks very looks like
a very promising exchange sacrifice but
what White has are these three miners
which can at least offer some fire power
to defend the position and of course
I'll just say this we weren't watching
this too closely but this will have been
under incredible time pressure by both
sides so as I scroll through these moves
if you're playing along with a computer
I'm sure the computer will find all
kinds of mistakes that's just to be
expected when you get this kind of
situation because there's going to be so
many tactics involved in a position like
this Queen f6 I'm sure there were more
candidate moves in that night eh -
Bishop a7 maybe a little controversial
and E 4 maybe that's a move he missed
because now the rooks come off and like
I was saying with Eugene peril Stein
when you are down the exchange you
really want to not have your rook traded
off and when you're up the exchange as
Ron is here it's a great thing to
achieve so he's sacrificing the pawn on
e4 in order to do
and yeah my sense now is he's I guess
winning you know he still needs to
consolidate and the king looks a little
frightened on each one but this now
looks like it's winning for white so a
big miss by Samuel Savion from a
position that let's say right here looks
very promising for black and it's kind
of a miracle that this works out for
white because what he this intuitive
play actually I will stand by this
position I will say that here black must
have at least compensation here for the
exchange and there's a number of
different things but Queen f6 and Bishop
a7 can't be the right thing to do
let me put it this way just on an
intuitive level the bishop is doing
something here so we need to make our
other pieces work over there whereas the
bishop here is just investing a tempo in
a piece that is already doing something
on a different diagonal so I'm sure
there was time pressure but this all
fell apart with this nice movie for here
and now white white is simply winning in
our game position we have this and yeah
this is is over so a sad loss for Samuel
well and you can see live it end after
we go off the air at us chess champs
calm the games continue even after our
show ends we're on the air you know this
is an abbreviated session about 90
minutes every day right except for
whenever there's a field clincher near
the end but at this time Jesse it's time
to grab your flag alright because we've
got some upcoming events to talk about
correct of course if you don't get this
blind patriotism well it's not blind we
have a good reason for it because coming
up in just a few days it's the World
Chess Championship and we are gonna be
having our abbreviated coverage right
here from st. Louis with the match in
London world chess championship Carlsen
Cara Juana with the Superfriends the
a-team yeah so Sarah Juan
Jen Shehadeh and more recently and that
all starts in just three days at us
chest champs calm and yeah it's gonna be
overlapping this tournament it's gonna
be insane we're gonna have two
completely different broadcast going on
all day it's gonna be a great time and
they're also going to be covering of the
world women's Chess Championship the big
64 player knockout now they're in the
round of 32 by the time we get the
coverage going they'll be in the round
of 16
Irina crushed the lone American female
left she's taking on June when June
actually right now she's in the midst of
that match I think game 2 is tomorrow
she is down one point she needs to win
to stay in and potentially move to the
round of 16 we'll see what happens when
today and chess covers the world and
world women's chess championships
starting in three days and then after
that we have a norm tournament coming up
it's the st. Louis Invitational
grandmaster norm field international
master norm field who will be the next
emerging stars in the world of chess and
then we close out the year once again in
London we will have coverage full
coverage right here in st. Louis the top
four players with a grand chest or
Fabiano Cara wanna hit Cara Nakamura
MVL and Levon Aronian are gonna be
playing in a miniature knockout
classical rapid and blitz all rated by
my favorite the universal rating system
and of course the most important part
the winner is the grand chess to our
champion it's going to be awesome very
very exciting chess will be happening
starting on December 11th okay so the
stories of the day Jesse we have a
player in group a and a player in Group
B that are still in perfect standing
Jeffry Zhang of course the geoffrey
zhang show the express is rolling down
the tracks yeah can anyone stop him
we'll see but a great victory a
complicated amazing game against
Alexander Shimano and over in Group B a
game that we didn't really get to look
at too much the good friends played each
other the Dutchman van forest and keval
is really they show up together they're
you know they're talking together but
no doubt they had a very intense game
today white came away with the victory
as Lucas van forest now stands two for
two and we'll see which of those players
if either can maintain their perfect
standing after tomorrow and maybe beyond
right and the guy who Timur gave a free
point to also won against big Mick so we
got ya those are the two players all
right and so that will do it for today
thanks for stopping in and joining us
this show was produced by the world's
greatest production B team Tami Hyde is
the streamer and we had Isaac's rants on
graphics and audio as always Danny
Machuca is your technical director and
for Grand Master Jesse cried my name is
Ben Simon we will see you tomorrow at
3:30 p.m. Central Time and you can catch
the games a little bit earlier at 1 p.m.
at us chess champs calm until then we
say so long from the Show Me State
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you